[Applause]
[Music]
okay here are the questions from the
Internet
Robin F says I noticed Fred was wearing
a hoodie and nobody flinched
but all right Robert Bales the soldier
who killed 17 Afghan civilians should he
be tried in Afghanistan they actually
wrote a piece on that in The Guardian
saying that that he should I mean the
Afghans say that they the witnesses in
the village say that there were multiple
US soldiers who were shooting the
villagers not just one who knows if
that's true but I think that when you
invade a country and you occupy it for
10 years and you continuously kill their
civilians making them extremely hateful
and angry towards you the least you can
do when someone goes on a major shooting
rampage has allowed them to participate
in the investigation and be a part of
the punishment of those people and
simply whisk them out of the country I
think is is pretty harmful but Afghan
punishment I mean well you you would
still let the US military take the role
but you would allow Afghans to
participate in in the investigation what
it was but what is the compromise we're
gonna plea bargain down from so that so
that people that they trust which is not
the military that's been occupying and
killing them for a decade are part of
the investigation and can assure them
that if there's evidence that there's
more than one killer that they've
actually that those leads have been
followed okay
black night asks Wendy do you think
politics would be different if women
took a larger role in government or
would they behave just like men I've
commented I've commented on that very
issue before they get in government they
do act like men you do think so well I
think the evidence is there don't don't
could you just a smart just a strategic
and just a successful if they get you
know past policies are the constituents
like and they're taking me just as tough
as men I think the dynamic when women
get together in a room woman's natural
inclination is to find a solution
problem-solving flexible compromise you
know every big kahuna in the room you
can actually see some ground and I think
when women get in a room the dynamic is
different it's more productive and I
think we'll be better
but but because they have to fight that
image of women being softer they're very
often bigger Hillary's a pretty big hawk
golden my ear was no slouch and Aragon I
don't think women have to be anti
military anti defense they just in a
room they are ten Margaret Thatcher
Thatcher it was amazing to me because
she I mean she never allowed another
woman in her own cabinet in eleven years
she's also a woman in the 50s who got
educated in chemistry and law and had a
family and ran as a single woman and
never once in her entire life
played the sex card never she absolutely
used that femininity but Beauty her wit
her humor to run rings around these
stupid men around her but she never said
she never said I'm a woman I'm being
intact unfairly because I'm a woman she
never played that hard she never played
the card that Hillary played at some
points she never played the oh you can't
do this to me she played I'm as hard as
nails as everyone I'm a feminist who
doesn't believe there's a difference
between men and women in the public
sphere and we abide by the same rules
and God help you if you fight with 15
seconds on Hillary Clinton that woman
was maligned and abused since the minute
she stepped into public life with her
husband might be a close second more
abuse than a human being in politics
[Music]
Hillary Clinton Margaret Thatcher made
her own political career didn't latch on
to her husband
I'm sorry but she wanted me to like to
Senator in New York New York so why did
she subordinate herself a husband's
career yeah that's in politics okay
makes choices she made she made a choice
to put a man ahead of her that's not a
feminist
[Applause]
that was playing the sex card right
there it's the same identity card don't
explain you don't complain about
something doesn't mean it's not real
right
so just because someone doesn't complain
that the sections of operating in their
life or racism or homophobia operating
in their life does not mean that it's
not quite real no it just means and that
that is a real is a crucial difference
you have to make even if Margaret
Margaret Thatcher never complained about
it did not mean that it did not exist
oh of course her life couldn't vote but
it makes that triumph over it more it
seems it makes her triumph over it I
think greater than if you rested on
those kind of arguments to give yourself
some sympathy you don't have to rest on
those arguments but I don't I don't
believe you have to walk away from
calling a spade a spade whoa
[Applause]
[Applause]
do you think tim tebow is going to have
some growing pains well he's never been
late he must have blue balls I'll tell
you that well he hasn't he says he's a
virgin waiting you know this is how sick
religion is I mean yeah I mean this this
guy could get so much [ __ ] yeah talk
about backup oh my god
anyway why do you assume means he needs
a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we have no idea pull them tight ends for
anything do you think anyway he's coming
to New York judge by the way I talked to
him at the Oscar party he's a very sweet
comb very nice guy you know I mean I
obviously have problems with his
religiosity on the field and I'm tweeted
about it and made fun of him but I don't
just like the guy I think he's being
nice might have something to do with his
face how come you know I don't really
nice you need religion to be nice no
that's not what I said well it's like no
it isn't it's saying that the real
Christian is not someone going around
telling other people how to live their
lives but living their own life in a way
that shows the virtues and beauty of
what Christianity is about and that
seems to be what he's doing and that's
the right way to go that well anyway
he's on my team now the New York Jets so
I'm rooting for him and I think he is a
good player anyway the question is do
you think t-bo's gonna have some growing
pains or some serious temptations going
into the world's largest religious
social melting pot well he's playing in
New York he's playing I love it he's
playing in Joe Namath's old position and
Joe Namath old hat Joe Namath who got
more [ __ ] than God I mean you know God
wants [ __ ]
really is everyone gay now even God no
but not everyone straight that's true
that's my only point really spend in New
York I don't know how that works I mean
booed the football player yeah well I
mean if you if you're about your team
you kind of have to move there that's
where you practice way of the preseason
half your home games I mean I assume
he'll have to get a place in New Jersey
I guess so yeah I don't know at home
points you should get him on SNL oh I'm
sure that's gonna happen I mean I don't
know for sure about any of that sketchy
yeah that's right yeah remember you did
that's good oh I remember clearly yeah
Jason Sudeikis yeah is funny as [ __ ]
yeah I loved it I loved it I loved it
all right we're way over time we got
again thank you everybody appreciate you
coming Real Time with Bill Maher ask
Bill and it's guest your questions right
after the show at hbo.com